hi welcome to another episode of the
gadget lab show i'm nathan olivares
giles i'm christina bonnington and this
week we're taking a look at ridiculous
iphone accessories and the death of
google reader so first up christina
bonnington has some really kind of
what wacky uh nuts stuff yeah so
you know just for fun we decided to
round up some funny
fun bizarre ios accessories and uh
yeah so here's one of the ones that we
found it is a uh it's a
charger and it is uh
a flask yes i like it i like it it's
less nerdy you know so instead of having
you know this charger that's clearly a
charger now your friends can you know be
all like oh you're just an alcoholic not
not a nerd um you know so if that's your
thing or a nerdy alcoholic yeah i don't
know it's kind of it's kind of hefty um
it comes with a couple of different
uh connector cables and so it's got two
usb ports right there
and yeah pretty cool so i can hook this
up this looks like a micro usb i can
hook it up to an android can work with
the iphone
it even says tablet here
charging the ipad off of my back pocket
yeah
that's cool yeah that's cool
another one we got is kind of futuristic
it is a laser
this little thing
shoots out a laser keyboard which you
can use and it actually works better
than i thought it would um
let's see it projects
projects a keyboard onto a flat surface
and then you can type
syncs over bluetooth
it does not work if you if you want to
do it like on your lap or something
that's uneven it won't work at all um
it's and you can get it from think geek
that's pretty cool
what's it like actually tapping on a
hard surface because that seems like it
might you know annoy my fingertips after
a while you know
it senses uh your your touch so it's
just kind of it's
it's not too bad it's kind of
interesting i do more like
finger finger tapping than before more
hunting than full hand typing right on i
dig it
and then the last thing we've got which
is actually so
it seems kind of ridiculous to me but i
could see it i mean i can certainly see
it being useful to parents it's um like
a toddler toy that you can put an iphone
in the middle it's got a mirror on the
other side it's got you know teething
rings um
you know this just you know
anything you know you can be a good
parent or a bad parent with giving your
kids your ios devices or whatever but
this totally just seems like a really
easy way to be like bad parent and be
like here kid just play on your on the
iphone with this and you can chew on it
and you can play angry birds is it
waterproof tell me it's waterproof
i don't
and you know knocked over drinks and i
don't believe it's waterproof it does
have a protective case on the front so
um you know it's protected and then the
back your iphone locks in so they won't
be able to get the iphone out
fisher price quality too that's good
it's good it's good quality that'll mess
around
awesome well thanks uh you can see a
full gallery of all these different
crazy accessories on gadget lab
christine put that together and create
including like a crazy isn't there like
a crazy hand iphone okay there's some
weird iphone cases yeah
so take a look
all right matt honan he's here to talk
to us about a dear old friend who's
going to be riding off into the
sunset that's right nate google reader
everybody's or nearly everybody's
favorite news reader application it's a
web-based rss
feed manager from google
is going away they announced that it's
they're going to kill it on july 1st
2013. it's heartbreaking it's sad it's
devastating it's terrible news
tell me more
well it is all those things and not at
all unforeseen sadly like the uh you
know they haven't been updating it just
about at all for years yeah launched in
2005 and it's been it's
gotten a few new features but none uh no
significant ones in the past several
years other than stuff taken away yeah i
mean i think like
last month we saw it go down and google
didn't even bother to acknowledge that
for a few days
the last time there was really an update
to it though before that was in 2011
when they took away its sharing
functions and rolled those as just plus
one buttons
so i mean what about monetizing it
there's no ad space can they make any
money off this thing is that why they're
killing it i mean it's not making any
money but i'm sure they could you know
if you think about it it's really
dominates that rss reader market and
that tends to be a probably a market of
people who are reading a lot every day
which means you're probably talking
about people with an education which
means you're probably talking about
people who have money yeah you know and
those are people who are valuable
readers uh and so it's a little bit
surprising they haven't ever monetized
it
but you know certainly uh
i think other people are going to rush
in that space and try and fill this void
and figure out what to do and another
way it seems like they could have
monetized there are so many apps yeah
use google reader this is going to
affect so many apps it really was the
defining rss
you know feed you know reading app like
there's really nothing else out there
that matches it
i think it's a major bummer that it's
going to be going away but
where where do we go from here you know
if you're one of those folks who has you
know 100 different feeds coming into
google reader every day what are you
going to do now can you can you export
you can export yeah you can download
your data and exporter google makes
pretty easy to export your data and then
there are there's already
kind of a land rush going on of
companies rushing in to fill the void
who want to make it a really seamless
thing like i saw something from feedly
yesterday uh
basically saying they're building a
google reader clone and that if you sign
up with them it'll be a seamless
transition uh digg.com announced that
they are going to rush out a uh
alternative to google reader and they're
now being being run by a former googler
right they are being run by a former
googler yeah and uh so i mean it's going
to be a uh you know it's going to be an
interesting couple of months i think as
we see like because there hadn't been a
whole lot of innovation in that space
like google readers so to find that
market that there were much innovation
it could be good you know it could be
really good it might be a good thing is
google offering any alternatives maybe
something with google plus or are they
just kind of saying
forget it i mean i think they're sort of
saying forget it i think you know the
thing is they're all these petitions
like save google reader google please
don't kill reader well the thing is
google knows exactly how many people are
using google reader exactly how long
they're spending in it exactly what
they're doing like google knows like
google has analytics resistance is
futile yeah and uh you know i mean they
you know i'm sure they have found that
people are getting their news from other
signals and that's probably when they're
moving on that's a guess but you know i
mean it seems like they're they're
seeing people get their news from google
plus or get their news from twitter and
and they've decided that that's where
where the future is well google is
moving on i i guess we should too so
i guess that's it for this episode of
the gadget lab show uh tune in next week
as we'll have more insane
cool awesome stuff
hopefully no more beloved products
shutting down though